If you recall, Muhammad Hijab was the
one who gave Andrew Tate the keys to the
UMAH. Hijab is the one who interviewed
Tate shortly after his conversion and
who announced to the Muslim world. Here
is your new champion. Defend him. One
thing I want to say to the Muslim people
is we must show loyalty and unity with
Andrew Tate in the sense that he is now
one of our brothers and it is
absolutely unforgivable to say things
that some of these feminist Muslims have
been saying and in fact if anything they
need to be the ones who are refuted.
Andrew Tate now is a brother of ours.
His sins have been completely wiped
away. Uh, and and that really is that.
Now, Hijab and Tate are both
narcissists, so they're good at making
themselves centers of attention, which
helps them with social media and da. But
ultimately, everything they do is done
out of self-interest.
Tate converted because he was about to
be arrested and he knew there was one
religious community that would gladly
defend someone with his view of women
because their prophet had a similar view
of women. Hijab wanted to be the da guy
who carried Tate across the threshold so
to speak for two reasons. One, he knew
that Tate would be an amazing poster boy
for Da. If Muslims see a famous person
convert to Islam, they'll get excited.
and they'll want more da and they'll
support people like Muhammad
hijab. Two, hijab obviously wanted Tate
under his umbrella of influence so that
he could have access to Tate's fans,
thus expanding his DA brand. Fast
forward 2 and 1/2 years to 2025 and
things are not going well for the Andrew
Tate Dawa experiment. Most Muslims seem
to have abandoned Tate because almost
everything he does is haram and they've
realized that he's giving young Muslims
the impression that it's cool to violate
the commands of Allah and Muhammad. But
this puts Da clowns like Muhammad Hijab
in an awkward position because if they
denounce and distance themselves from
Andrew Tate, he may leave Islam and even
become an enemy of Islam. In a new
video, Hijab explains why it's a bad
idea for Muslims to attack Tate for his
behavior. But interestingly, Hijab, as
the opportunistic narcissist he is, is
still using Tate to his advantage, and
you're about to see how. You're also
about to learn the most important lesson
you'll ever learn about narcissists.
So, Hijab is having a discussion with
Tam Khan, who was the man praying with
Tate in the viral video posted after
Tate's conversion in 2022, just a week
before Hijab told the UMA that they
needed to support and defend Tate at all
costs. Hijab and Khan discuss whether
Tate's conversion was authentic. They
agree that it was. Then they consider
some of the problems Tate has been
causing and Hijab shares a story about
one of Muhammad's companions who even
though he had good intentions ended up
helping the enemies of Muhammad. And
Hijab compares this companion to Andrew
Tate. If Andrew Tate does the same
thing, and this is where the fine line
is, he's actually at that fine line of
right now where he's he's aiding the
enemies of Islam in a sense. He's
indirectly. Oh, he's aiding us. He's
been aiding us since the moment he
converted. But he's not doing I would
say this is where the Muslims have to be
careful as well because just
like yes, he's aiding the enemies of
Islam in an indirect manner and that's a
major sin. To be fair, hijab, he's not
aiding us anywhere near as much as you
and Ali Dawa. Yes, he's aiding the
enemies of Islam in an indirect manner
and that's a major sin. It's wrong. I I
believe it's it's not justifiable
Islamically. But it's not the kind of
sin that as you mentioned would
excommunicate him outside because if
that was the case then would have been
excommunicated by the prophet. So Tate
is aiding the enemies of Islam but he's
not an apostate. So what should Muslims
do about his behavior which they can't
seem to
control? How hard should Muslims push?
There is zero benefit in pushing Andrew
Tate to become an enemy of Islam. Zero
benefit. zero benefit. And if you if you
push him too much, a human being is a
human being is a human being. And it
like you you're going to push him. Do
you want him to become like a David
Wood? Do you want him to become like a
David
David Wood? Sorry, hijab, but ain't no
thing like me except me. Thanks for the
shout out, though. It's good to know
that in your mind I'm the ultimate
nightmare scenario for what Andrew Tate
could become. Do you want him to become
like a David Wood? Do you want him to
become like an enemy of Islam? Is that
what you want? Cuz that's going to bring
people out of Islam. That's what he's
going to do. So, Muslims better keep
quiet about Andrew Tate or you'll push
him too hard and he'll become like the
dizzle and lead tons and tons of people
out of Islam.
And I think that Muslim community have
to really tone it down with this. Yeah.
Because at the end of the day, like I
said, there's zero benefit in this man
leaving Islam and becoming enemy of
Islam. It will lead to more apostasies.
It will lead to less people coming into
Islam, especially those who came into
Islam through him. And there's a lot.
And we know that. Get
it? Exposing the terrible behavior of a
popular Muslim influencer will lead to
apostasy. So, it's better to let the
popular influencer do what he wants.
This brings us to today's lesson about
narcissists. I promised you a lesson and
you'll get it right after a brief word
about this video's sponsor. Pretend you
were one of the gullible teenagers who
started worshiping Andrew Tate. Your mom
tried to warn you, but you didn't listen
to your own mother. Here you are a few
years later and you finally realize that
the woman who gave birth to you deserved
far more respect and devotion than that
walking misogynistic clown emoji Andrew
Tate. So you need to apologize. How do
you make things right with your mom? Get
her some handpicked treasures from the
places where Jesus walked. I'm talking
about signing her up for some arts
boxes. Your mom will love them. She'll
get candles, Israeli spice mixes,
olivewood carvings, mosaic art,
decorations, cosmetics, candy, games,
all kinds of things delivered right to
her door. And she'll forgive you for
treating her so terribly. There's a new
box every season, four new boxes every
year. Of course, even if you're not
apologizing to your mom for ignoring her
warnings about Andrew Tate, you can get
an Artza box for yourself, like a real
Top G. If you'd like to start getting
your Artsa boxes, the link is in the
description. Be sure to use the promo
code Dizzle to get a discount and to let
them know who sent you.
Now, what can we learn about narcissists
from the clips we saw? I dropped a hint
right before I told you about arts
boxes. What's hijab's real point about
Andrew Tate? Hijab insists that exposing
the terrible behavior of a popular
Muslim influencer will lead to
apostasy. So, it's better to let the
popular influencer do whatever he wants.
Don't expose
him. But hijab is a narcissist. And
whenever a narcissist seems like he's
trying to help someone or seems like
he's trying to help your community, you
should always, always, always ask
yourself, what's in it for the
narcissist? Because I guarantee you
there's something in it for him or he
wouldn't be wasting his precious time.
Can you think of any reason Muhammad
Hijab might be telling the Muslim
community not to push too hard against
popular Muslim influencers who've been
caught in a
scandal? Wait a
moment. Isn't Muhammad Hijab a popular
Muslim influencer who's been caught in a
scandal? Hasn't hijab been exposed for
marrying secret extra wives and lying to
them about his intentions and for
basically turning them into prostitutes
and for using a photoshopped screenshot
and a fake AI confession to cover up
what he did and even for blackmailing a
shake and ruining his life because the
shake wouldn't help him lie about one of
his
victims. Should Muslims call out
Muhammad hijab for his
behavior? Of course not. Even though
he's aiding the enemies of Islam by
giving us endless ammunition, he's not
an
apostate. If you keep pushing him, you
might turn him into an enemy of Islam.
You might even turn him into David Wood
in his
dreams. So, just think about all the
people who will leave Islam if you
expose Muhammad Hijab. You don't want to
be responsible for accelerating the
avalanche of apostasy, do
you? No matter what he does, you need to
let him get away with all of it. He's
too important to
fail. That's the real point Hijab was
making. And the point I'm making to you
is that you should always be looking for
this sort of thing when you're dealing
with someone like Muhammad
Hijab. Since the videos about hijab's
secret hotel wives just came out, the
moment I saw he had posted a video about
Andrew Tate, I thought he's obviously
going to use this to protect himself
from criticism. And he didn't
disappoint. Now, let me speak to Hijab
directly since I know he's
watching.
Muhammad, don't worry about being
exposed.
You've picked your followers
well. Nothing I say and nothing you do
is going to diminish their loyalty to
you. If I even thought for a second that
this video would cause problems for you,
I wouldn't have posted it. Right now,
you're still too valuable to what we're
trying to do for us to let you fail. So,
cheer up, Hijab. You're not finished.
until I say you're finished.
[Music]